[Music]
hey guys in this video we're going to
talk about the 19 slate in the final
season of Game of Thrones
there are many spoilers regarding the
leader of the White Walkers so let's
just jump in it in the season a premiere
we will not see the night king he's
confirmed to be absent in episode 1 by
the cast lineup for that very episode
even though will not see the new king in
season 8 premiere will see his army of
the Dead which will attack in the story
castles of howsomever and house Karstark
just a just a table did the wall falls
one must wonder Eden a king's arm is
attacking castles in episode 1 how come
the night king their leader is not with
them
that's because night king has other
plans it's the night King's master plan
already talked about this a few times in
the past but what that master plan is
it's basically the knighting attack in
the north on two fronts but to achieve
that he's got to go south all the main
characters singing trance as well as all
of us fans expect a great battle to be
fought in the north and the enemy is to
attack from the north but the night king
will surprise them the north will indeed
face a hundred thousand strong army of
the White Walkers Center whites in
Episode one with the two castles falling
but the night King will 5 is there into
the far south across the whole Westeros
and will raise the dead does the entire
continent will be facing a horde whites
overnight basically the night king will
be creating a huge arm in the south
while his current army takes minor
castles in the north
it'll get to see the night king in
Episode two but when the things will
really go down is in episode three the
night Kings current army that numbers
over 100,000 whites and White Walkers
will come from the north and the night
King himself at the new army of the Dead
that he's been creating south during the
first two episodes of the final season
will come from the south when a FAL will
have to fight on two fronts and not only
that but the night King will attack from
the inside as well through hidden
passage has learned from a sirloin in
season wonder hidden passageways built
or the crypts of NFL so the Lords of
Winterfell could escape in emergency mr.
lewin actually offered a theme to use it
to escape winter fell enjoy the Nights
Watch when renze came that hidden
passage might even be the Stano arias
passing through in the official game
from season a teaser
basically surrounded if you have been
following Game of Thrones Season 8 news
and leaked photos you know that this big
battle from Winterfell is set to take
place in season 8 episode 3 as it's been
confirmed by the actor who plays the
night king let him a verdict for declare
the news live during a fan convention he
hungry he said and spoiled in the third
episode of the last season there's a
battle that creators intended to be a
historic moment in television almost the
full episode will be about the battle it
will take about one hour verdict states
that they filmed this battle for three
months in the vein and rain outdoors and
then for another month in a huge studio
which makes this far in the way the most
labor-intensive battle sequence in the
show's history and therefore in the
history of TB I can tell you that there
will be no shortage of surprises in
season 840 continues there will be a lot
of dragons the night king will return
and in the season the biggest battle for
the throne will be completed
Entertainment Weekly's cover story from
a few months back gave us an inside look
into the final game eternal season
through the eyes of James Hebert it's
shaping up to be what probably almost
certainly is the longest consecutive
battle sequence in cinema history
Hebert said and continued with they work
to try and find other ones out there
like the one in the two towers in the
Lords of the Rings which is about 40
minutes and in the movie 13 assassins
which was also around 40 minutes this is
going to be longer than 40 minutes it's
pretty nuts HBO has also gone all-in on
sets first it's Nate building the
venerable set to make it as close to
real castle as possible according to
Heber the crew was up to the challenge
the massive expanding the Winterfell set
you commander around point the camera at
any direction and shows more Winterfell
one of Directors pointing out that even
in a big-budget Marvel or Star Wars
movie they usually only build what the
actors are gonna stand directly in front
of and filling the rest with green
screen but for this set and a few others
as well they built it as 360 degrees set
so you don't have to fill it with
special effects you don't have to favor
one particular angle you can have
cameras follow people around you can do
unusual angles and come up with
different things on the day of shooting
set allows a lot more creativity and it
helps the actors no acting required
they're running around it sets fighting
with fake blood and snow snow flying
everywhere torches burning fires and
smoke it feels like you're right there
to film the Battle of Winterfell
HBO built an enormous green screen in
order to bring their vision of an epic
battle to life so who was gathered there
for this week's long shoot first we got
the unsullied and the unsullied are not
the only pea
Ramez those who are part of the battle
of interval there are also the Trekkie
riders finally there's also shadow we
think is a norton army and also there's
a trebuchet and said multiple people
will fill flaming swords in the battle
against the dead but of all the
characters we know buried and arrogance
the one most closely associated with the
flaming sword seems like Gandhari own
shared a trick feed a few people go so
have a fair amount of screen time and
will most definitely fight at this
battle this battle is directed by miguel
supporting the guy behind some of the
best episodes of get materials like Hart
home in some winter and battle the
bastards talking about this huge battle
from Winterfell it's brutal said star
peter dinklage tyrion lanister it makes
the Battle of the bastards look like a
theme park writing earlier about this
historic sequence james gilbert called
it wall-to-wall action and detail how he
jumps between stories of several
different characters but we also know
for a fact is that the winner and will
not fall a winner fell the night king
will win this battle it'll be a huge
defeat for living men FL is on fire the
night king has won as you might expect
this battle will leave many dead check
out this image of corpses strewn across
the ground outside the Winterfell
settimana class we can see what looks
like a feel strewn with the bodies to
the left of the castle including some
that look like horses
Mima we also have images of a pile of
body part props outside a castle and a
blood left on the castle walls as it
money glass the grounded Meg Ramon
quarry was littered with corpses
unlike an money glass someone was able
to get up close and personal with the
bodies there are all kinds of corpses
the most surprising corpses were the
ones bearing the Kraken sigil of house
Greyjoy
they don't expect egregious to be part
of this battle but if they own already
saved Yara by episode 3 then I don't see
where else they will be however it could
also be a surprise attack Winterfell
with the golden company either before or
after the night he attacked it anyway
this is more in line with what I was
expecting this skeletal corpses could be
the bodies so White's
or they could be people flesh fried by
dragon fire next up corpse blobs HBO
likely spread these things all over the
battlefield and covers them in some snow
from distance they look like discrete
corpses rather than a bunch of bodies
affixed one plate in the stays the miss
frost the direwolf marker over as well
as the marker for Dennis and Sally
forces but unfortunately the Norton arm
Union solid are not going to be the only
casualties for the living it is
confirmed that most of the track you
will photo tonight King as
and then shortly after be brought back
to life by the white walkers to
basically act as their minions here you
can see the tricky whites riding
horseback but we cannot say for a fact
although it's being hinted by the
official T's is the Danny will at some
point burn our form of the track you
loyalists here we can see the tracking
marker being burned does that for share
of Danny burning the track he that fell
during the battle for Winterfell maybe
after this epic Battle of Winterfell the
nat king will conquer the north and the
living or least what's left of them will
have to retreat south and once again
parlay with Cersei and urine which gets
us to another confirmed event it's not
only the living who will go south the
nat king will as well
Johnston will return to King's Landing
in Episode four the night king and
episode after the final major spoiler we
know is taking place in the final season
of Kim Jones is the nat king burning
down the capital King's Landing using
his dragon balerion as some of you may
know for the final season now given
three ons the production for the very
first time instead of filming his
landing scenes in Dubrovnik they decided
to make a huge King's Landing set in
Belfast and fill most of the scenes
there why did they build city buildings
to resemble the study they used for in
planning all these years instead of
filming an actual medieval town says
they usually do that's because he
materials is not allowed to burn cities
to the ground as construction for King's
Landing set focused on polishing the
city bowls it's a disaster it's a famous
Dubrovnik landmark has been faithfully
reproduced the crew built a whole city
street at one end there's the gate and
that the other the front of the red keep
in between their own main or buildings
the most notable are surrogates in the
King's Landing don't however as you can
see in these leaked photos the set has
been modified to appear burn down the
huge bridge between the Milosh towers
the city gate has been obliterated in
the towers that once protected as have
fallen the nut King has burned down a
huge portion of the capital including a
slanting dome using his undead dragon
how can I know for sure that this is the
Nike is doing rather than a result of
Cersei using wildfire and burning down
the entire city even though burned
King's Landing set would seem to support
the arrearage search save burns down the
entire city the answer is no wildfire is
not the reason this part of insulating
set is being burned down is Dragon Fire
how do I know it's simply due to effect
that show built the King's Landing set
mainly to do lie power techniques it
means that some parts of the capital
will be burned down by a dragon as
firing gay materials is portrayed by
live art techniques the necking Schrag
on that is responsible for a huge
portion of the capital being burned down
has also been spotted on the skin's
landing set yes dragons are visual
effects magic mostly however men
performers have to interact with dragons
the number of methods are used to make
it work for example if Danny has to
touch the dragon's head any giant head
shaped object will do such as this phone
was used when the dragons for babies
this is nothing touching vissarion's
head in last season
if actors had to actually mount a dragon
part of its spine has to be physically
recreated which is exactly what it's
messy contraption against Linux that is
this massive contraption being on this
very same set means that the night King
will at some point this side to land in
King's Landing
perhaps in the final episode I've known
that Dragons will eventually fly over
King's Landing as brain saw it in his
vision of the future however I did not
quite expect it to be the night king
flying bazarian I expected it to be
Danny riding dragon perhaps it will be
both also remember this while prophecy
singham journals don't literally come
true visions on the other hand do
meaning the remaining two brains visions
from the future the shadow of a dragon
flying over King's Landing and the one
in which brain sees King's Landing
mentor with an empty throne room that
his it's real blown off will come true
in the final season
whichever dragon shows up and whoever
eyes that Cersei will be ready
Qyburn has made new scorpion ballista
for a screen as seen in this leaked
photo from King's Landing set it's not
only dragons will clash above King's
Landing
the entire living side will be there as
well as the entire army of the Dead then
solid and the track he also visit King's
Landing
or at least a little of them so right
Battle of Winterfell here you can see
the unsullied and what's left of the
track in marching towards King's Landing
gates
Cersei probably intends to use wildfire
and burn the entire King's Landing to
the ground once the living and the dead
start fighting inside our city and that
they get rid of all our enemies it's
possible that by this point Cersei Danny
and Jon Snow had teamed up and are
fighting the White Walkers together but
it's just as likely that Cersei won't
see the reason and then he has commanded
her armies to saw the city walls the
final battle between the living and the
dead will take place at his landing
judging by the leaked photos judging by
the destroyed King's Landing set at
first it seems like the night king has
won the final battle however it doesn't
necessarily mean that of course that the
final battle between the night King and
the living in King's Landing will leave
the capital
quite a bit ruined but it doesn't mean
that a knight King has won as a right
now these are the spoilers to have
regarding the knight King in a final
season of Game of Thrones we don't know
how he be defeated or if he is going to
be defeated for that matter
there are many endgame possibilities for
the knight king well he simply be
defeated or will he be healed or cured
as many popular theories claim or will
there be a new packet in the living and
the dead as my popular theory suggests
with Danny being part of that pact and
becoming tonight's queen or will donut
king and his forces prevail and conquer
all of Westeros there are many
possibilities regarding the knight Kings
endgame but three things regarding his
fate are certain the knight king will
not appear in episode 1 the nine king
will win the battle for Winterfell in
Episode three and a final battle against
the night king will be at King's Landing
leaving the capital burned down just
like Minerva and in ruins and as always
I hope you guys enjoyed this video if
you did please make sure to subscribe to
our Channel and I hope to see you in the
next one peace